British chocolate is better than
American chocolate
oo over here oh okay over here whoa sh
fire strongly agree I British chocolate
is better than American chocolate 100
you want to try some American British
uhhuh so that's the the one that you all
know from so these like these have trans
fats are these Americans that's American
they have transs these have trans fats
they have trans fats in
them illegal in other
countries delicious it's good delicious
yeah
mhm mhm mhm mhm mhm where where's your
glass going that's most important I mean
oh it's so good I don't know they're
both pretty damn
good Spike Le voice not my cup of
tea he's strongly disagrees is that a
serious serious wow you genuinely think
that no I just wanted to use that
LE quo
okay I know